here we go they're saying let me turn
off the stream I've heard that one
before
do I take the bait do I take the bait
and believe it do I believe that or do I
pull out ah the bird is the word
if you weren't familiar if you're super
new to chess
this means birds land okay
Bishop g7 Birds opening and I'm gonna
try this
hmm okay know what chop a knight go
after this pond play see five here
knight c6 Knight h6 - one of these - so
many choices and I don't have good
answers to all those I'd like this is a
start I think
or do i yeah let's get that seat pot
involved in men night c 6c 5 and then
knight c6 i have a lot of well not a lot
okay i have some flexibility with my
head light square Bishop g4 being the
more aggressive
there's also f5 my knight pretty much is
going to play here I think huh
d4 do i pin the knight or do I capture
and then play here I'm gonna chop that
up and now develop with the tempo I
don't know it's not a tempo but we'll
see how white recaptures I have to be
cautious of this possibility this pawn
push one example is Queen to here knight
c6 Bishop pin Bishop d7 and then pawn
push pawn sack actually no that's not
working the Queen on d4 would be hit if
there is that pawn move but anyhow this
has my this has some of my attention the
possibility if my bishop goes elsewhere
I'll say off the board off of this
diagonal the possibility for a 6b where
the e6 move is what I'm getting at
alright let's go the bishop in is
happening right here more development
ready to castle I want to be able to
castle and just then have the threat on
the Queen I think or is there something
with Bishop here there's Queen check and
if Knight blocks I could take the Bishop
and then take the Queen but at the end
of that I think I'm having to dodge
possible Forks on c7 so no things on
that one let's get more development in
here
castle if Knight c3 well I think I might
do this and I'll tell what makes my
bishop look like an idiot I am
supporting my Center and maybe I could
come out in this direction with my
LightSquared Bishop one day my opponent
does have a space advantage on the Kings
side okay I don't have any choice let's
recapture right away and let me also do
what
let me castle I'd like to get this move
in but I think white might be looking to
control that which is understandable but
um what about this is that gonna be
annoying to the night I think I'd like
to get rid of my light square bishop for
the night see if I can make that happen
okay I think I want to just take this
guy out I don't know I don't want to
tolerate that night anymore you need to
go you need to go Knight yep giving up
the light square bishop I do my opponent
hat okay again has having a space
advantage you know it's a little bit
difficult for me to maybe coordinate my
pieces so that's maybe another reason to
run in for that this I have to take
really good care of this c5 square and I
want to first and foremost make sure
that my knight can reside on this f5
square I do not want him to be kicked
away anytime soon
I think I'm starting to become better in
this position and this move right here
hang on hang on hang on if I do this no
I could do it I could do it I was
thinking Knight here is available but it
is not because I could actually take and
be on the Queen if I didn't have that
thread on the Queen after a knight 94
move pawn takes Knight then this might
be a big concern
a big concern to me because f6 and a 6
or maybe available I think I start to
stand better here pond push is uh it's
good I think now I still am in this pin
c4 could be played if I play d4 there's
maybe b5 I think this is as far as I
want to go I don't want to do I take
that bishop now I like my knight too
much I am in a pin but I am hitting B -
I'll do I'm gonna be very cautious in
fact if a3 is played I can't take well
no I could take the pawn because I'm on
c2 after that but I have to be cautious
of maybe some pawn push right now being
the case because I am in this pin let's
get this pawn up to stop the b4 advance
and also I'm gonna go forward again and
if this pond is gonna push forward my
rook is gonna have some play as
follow-up moves this rook where do you
think it's gonna go probably here if my
knight is challenged I could consider
night to h4 keeping it on the board okay
I take like this and and what okay wait
a second if I play here pawn push
exploiting this pin I don't like it so I
need to find a good square to go to this
seems pretty good still keeping a close
eye on the c5 square I'm ready to maybe
push forward here and then grab this
pond and then place this bishop in a pin
I think that'll translate into an
endgame and I think that's what we were
we're gonna be seeing right now it seems
super awkward to play a rip to see c3
right here there's like a little Flying
V formation going on here pawns on light
working well with my dark square bishop
and I think that that was probably
missed
so let's now sidestep the threat this is
a really big problem for white my only
concern right now is what
well I'm actually getting two minor
pieces here let me just think this one
through rook takes Bishop if rube takes
rook I play Knight takes Knight
if rook takes Bishop and Knight takes
Knight rook takes rook Knight check I
could just sidestep it that's winning
some stuff there so I think I think I
can do this in other words this is
working rook takes rook I think is best
I have a small time advantage and I want
to be cautious of this square this is my
only concern at this point
can white breakthrough at f7 I'm seeing
in two moves I can have it supported I'm
actually able to win on this pond though
I could oh if I really need to I can
always play rook to f8 I think once this
pond Falls everything Falls King here I
just have a check in pawn Falls so I'm
just gonna go with this and resort to a
very passive position for my rook but
there's no further progress that could
be made and this pond is ready to fall
next and well I think everything is
ready to fall now these pawns can't be
defended there's no other breaking
points for white here
I'm just gonna take this first I don't
think it really matters which pond and
just go a little fast
okay there's yeah there wasn't anything
to do right there towards the end good
game venko let's back up here
and I'll flip the board here looking at
it from your perspective let's see where
is their way to make some improvements
okay bird is the word but we enter
something yeah I guess d5 I haven't
played that much at all here
yeah let's see
let's see yeah okay d5 I'm basically
just looking to make this structure
flinch right now there is no d3 at least
not without having the Queen's come off
and going on castled yeah okay yeah good
point
I'm glad you referenced that Benko is
referencing that it kind of went
Frenchie yeah it did it did enter a
French defense type of structure now I
think there's I think there's an
improvements maybe right here I was
feeling pretty comfortable as soon as I
take out that night I think with this
resulting structure you know be I have
just I'm gonna end up having a lot of
space now this is strictly defensive
like my biggest concern is maybe you
camping out on the c5 square so I wonder
if that's something could go with I
wonder what the King move was for I
think maybe white was looking to play
this and maybe getting the King off of
this dog and learn or something oh no
actually yeah that's probably the
biggest thing just so there's no Queen
b6
and then taking the pawns type of stuff
but okay I'm securing my knight position
but right here right here I'm wondering
about one I'm wondering about yeah I'm
wondering about the Knights decision to
play dat E - what about a4 and then
trying to get on this scrap but I
actually I'm not even seeing that happen
I've seen Queen c7 pawn push and maybe
Bishop here well I don't know maybe I
think I would look closer into then I'm
not I'm not saying like white didn't
consider this but I think being maybe a
bit more general about things I think if
you're gonna sit back right here with 92
you're really waiting to just really get
beat up like I don't know if there's a
constructive plan for white to be going
with this night is really well-placed if
you're gonna if there's some idea with
the knight move I guess it is to try and
get rid of it real soon with 92 to g3
but I don't know something I think black
is standing better here
is there something earlier though the
right here if we don't have I'm kind of
drawn back to this Bishop for Knight
exchange because that's where we have
another that's where we have another
imbalance occurring here where well what
can you do I wonder if there's something
with the knight coming around here but
actually if you do that maybe I have
this f6 strike so I guess it's kind of
tough or after Knight seats free Bishop
here could you try this right now how
about Knight d2 B 3 C 5 I think that
could really mess with me how about this
how about this as an idea this this
Knight d2 move and as a follow up you
might want to be considering h3 g4 stuff
and then these guys may be one of one of
these two maybe both turn out to be a
bit out of play so it may be this is an
idea I think I don't I don't know what a
computer would be suggesting here but
certainly worth a closer look I say that
quite a bit but anyhow avoiding this
exchange in a position where you have
a space a spatial advantage on the Kings
side with h3g for ideas maybe that could
turn out to be pretty decent although I
guess the most direct thing black would
have in response to Knight d2 is Knight
f6 and then maybe a pawn push but it is
giving this knight the e the e4 square I
don't know it's a new it's a new look a
new take on this position for sure to
avoid the knight for Bishop exchange I
think I start to stand better right now
I don't know if there's a way you could
take advantage of this pawn structure it
is to focus your attention on c5 if
you're not going to have that under
control I think black is better in such
a position